deux nouveaux académiciens sous la
coupole il s'agit de georges duby
d'andré france heures ils ont tous les
deux été élu aujourd'hui par la verte
assemblée nous allons en parler cinéma
maintenant avec le dernier film de
patrice leconte vous le remarquez il est
à côté de moi on peut le voir depuis
hier sur les accros française sans titre
c'est donc tandem et les interprètes
sont jean rochefort et gérard jugnot qui
sont nos invités ce soir ma droite
georges faure à ma gauche gérard jugnot
qui commence pour nous raconter ce
qu'elle filme tandem c'est l'histoire
d'un couple d'une équipe difficile à
dire mais j'ai vu le signe tout à
l'heure change pas qu'est ce que ces
tandems c'est l'histoire oui d'amis
d'une amitié entre deux hommes etc ce
qui est assez bouche croix dans le ville
succès aux deux hommes qui en dehors de
leur cocon qui est souvent représentée
par une voiture de ce qu'ils font de la
radio leur espérance a effectivement
c'est inouï
vous êtes une star de la radio vous
poser des questions c'est ce qui
s'appelle la langue au chat des
questions à 10 20 ou 100 france mais
cela ce soir et alors nous sommes de
l'os iliaque technicien-chauffeur c'est
gérard l'homme à tout faire
l'homme à tout faire et ça dure depuis
très longtemps je crois il ya une amitié
plus profond qui est entre et tous et le
monde extérieur le raid hostile
je pense que c'est un peu aussi ça le
film et c'est plein de choses de films à
toi g20 je ne suis que vale oui c'était
un petit peu le factotum c'est vrai mais
quand même super bowl est censé je suis
de sganarelle sancho pansa je préfère
sganarelle parce que son show pensait
plus à peu mais oui il ya tout ça que
c'est à la fois une amitié sûr mais
rentrer c'est c'est comme les valet de
comédie c'est vrai que ça pourrait être
écrit pas
écrit par molière simplement les règles
de la référence et plus contemporaine tu
sais ces rapports entre maîtres et
valets quoi avec moi je suis la fouace
son papa sa nounou sont son souffre
douleur
elle est formidable et 10 buts oui oui
et alors c'est tout c'est cette vie de
couple alors on va voir de suite un
extrait rapide qui qui est peut-être pas
le plus significatif du film il est
intéressant car c'est un vrai moment de
folie
donc vous êtes dans votre voiture gérard
jugnot conduit il s'arrête d'un seul
coup parce qu'il a vu ou cru avoir vu un
énorme chien rouge qui traverse
traversent la chaussée regarder on
comprend assez bien calé le rend la
sciotte justement mais où est ce qui
s'est passé
un chien et non avec des yeux pieuvre
très brouillon aussi oui voyez michel
j'ai pas rêver ben voyons la région est
connu pour ça y'a un gros chien rouge
qui passe son temps à traverser les
routes pour tester les réflexes des
conducteurs
mon plus rien la bête immonde watts
avoir fini sa journée ou bien elle aura
eu peur de prendre un coup de par
charles darwin qu on ne plaisante pas
michel bon alors qu'est ce qu'on fait on
attend la nuit pour voir ces chiens
rouge feu doux danser la rumba dans la
lumière des phares bi ou bien on repart
tout fait attendez une minute
je vous reconnais vous appuyer leur
thèse
c'est extraordinaire voulait on va faire
les photos ma peine
attention monsieur ne bougeait plus vous
allez être foule bien
souriez alors vous avez deux rôles qui
se relancent constamment là l'autre vous
appuyez véritable menace sur l'autre
vous êtes donc la star un peu cabotin et
vous gérard vous êtes donc un petit peu
l'homme aux hordes mais quand même
qu'ils qui préserve constamment ça ça
quand vous travaillez dans ces cas là
vous travailler véritablement ensemble
l'un avec l'autre l'un contre l'autre
c'est à dire que nous avons eu la chance
et il avant on ne peut pas travailler
sans chance dans ce genre de
l'expérience et je crois un gérard que
dès le premier jour il s'est créé des
affinités et tout tout tout à rouler
alors je dis c'est simple mais c'est la
chance si le facteur chance de la
rencontre patrice nous a réunis et je
trouve qu'il a eu une excellente idée il
écrit surtout un scénario superbe et des
personnages qui tranche 10 ans mais
parce qu'on part sur une véritable
comédie et on change un petit peu de cap
vert une comédie un peu tragique et très
attachante
oui c'est ça que je suis très émue
d'avoir fait cela parce que bon c'est
vrai qu'il en s'amusant dans l'essonne
mais il ya aussi qu'ils sortent avec les
yeux un peu rouge parce qu'ils ont été
émis pas de tristesse mais deux
d'humanité et le personnage que moi que
j'interprète par rapport à agents et les
talons un petit peu comme ça deux
étalons humain qui est la référence et
d'abord d'un poème de génération qui est
universel aussi ça c'est très
intéressant d'un homme vieillissant et
d'un homme jeune et 6 intéressant s'il
pourrait tromper c'est ça qui est
formidable
on fait beaucoup de tandem entre deux
personnes de même génération là et aussi
cet apport père fils ou et c'est un
problème par rapport à ça le coup jeudi
riac ce film ou bien vous êtes riche et
une pomme et les crayons et là patrice
loko h au mas un trio qui va ce qui va
se renouveler je leur prends la clé
d'autres idées autour du ce même couple
un petit peu je pense parce qu'ils sont
entre pierre richard et depardieu ce qui
s'est fait vous pensez à faire pire
espèce de suite de temps mais on n'est
pas question pour le moment tout à fait
ravi parce que ça a été un bonheur à
plaisir et pour le cinéma français je
trouve cette infinité de l'intérêt sans
pitié vous si on a oublié d'irak et film
est admirablement par le conte est
éclairé par denis le noir de façon
épatant on reconnaît pas toujours notre
hexagone et ça c'est intéressant
un beauf in may voilà ben ça vos films
très bien donc je vous rappelle le titre
c'est donc tandem avec donc jean
rochefort gérard jugnot sylla film de
patrice leconte s'est depuis hier sur
les écrans français
moi je t'avoue donner maintenant les
rapports du